Oh
[Music]
Shadowhunters it's the Angels & Demons
fantasy show that gives us all the
fields stay tuned until the end to hear
about the huge bombshell that producers
just announced spoiler alert this video
contains spoilers from all seasons if
you're new here subscribe to the things
to catch our newest videos don't forget
to hit that notification bell to never
miss a video and check out our community
feature now here are the 10 most
heartbreaking moments from Shadowhunters
the Malick goodbye okay first let's go
back to season 2 of Shadowhunters to
wallow in the dark misery of the Magnus
and Alec goodbye fans called it the
breakup of the century in the episode
titled awake arise or be forever fallen
we witnessed the tragic loss of a
beautiful relationship
Magnus thought Alec could be trusted
forever but then he found out about the
soul-sword Alec knew he had to put his
people first so he formed an alliance
with the sealy Queen he really regretted
lying to Magnus who was distracted by
things at the Institute Magnus reflected
on their relationship and remembered how
the two originally connected he
remembered that Alec always accepted him
for who he is
after everything settled down Alec tried
to talk to Magnus about their
relationship after all they'd been
through it seemed that their
relationship was invincible
but while Magnus understood why Alec did
what he did he just couldn't get over
the betrayal
so Magnus said goodbye to Alec fans
nearly drowned in their tears over this
epic breakup this had fans begging for
Malick to get back together luckily they
did get back together in the season
finale phew that was a rough one the
moment Simon turned into a vampire you
guys remember when Camille attacked
Simon I mean of course you do then
Raphael carried Simon's body to the
Institute and that's when he had the big
talk with Clary about what to do since
he had vampire essence in his body they
had two options say goodbye to the world
forever or allow him to become a vampire
Clary chose the latter of the two
options so Clary Jace and Raphael buried
Simon and waited for him to emerge from
the earth as a vampire when Simon
finally did
it was now very pleased with clarice
decision his reaction to becoming a
vampire is totally heartbreaking
he asked Clary what happened and she
explained that he was no longer mortal
then he got all freaked out about his
teeth and the fact that he couldn't say
the word God anymore
he called himself repulsive but Clary
tried to remind him that he was still
the same person and still her best
friend that didn't really give him the
warm fuzzies he said he was a monster
and told her to stay away from him
it was clear that they were not BFFs
anymore
his reaction to becoming a vampire was
absolutely heartbreaking but what's a
girl to do Jace recites the parabatai
oath do you guys remember that moment in
season 2 where Jace finds Alec as he's
slipping away and recites the parabatai
oath dude serious acting chops on
Dominic Sherwood that guy's good anyway
Jace is sitting by Alec side and then we
see a flashback of their parabatai
ceremony when we cut back to Jason Alec
in the present time Jace is reciting
their parabatai vows he is so emotional
when he repeats the vows from their
ceremony they keep cutting back to the
original ceremony and then back to
Jace's weepy face followed by shots of
Alex lifeless face it's almost too much
so then Alex starts to really slip away
and Jace thinks he's lost him so he
picks up his lifeless body and holds him
while he recites the final phrase of
their ceremony vows through his tears of
sorrow suddenly Alec opens his eyes and
recites the final phrase of their vows
for real that gave us all the fields
that bond between Alec and Jace is so
strong those two have been through so
much together it's not hard to see why
Jace was able to bring him back from the
brink when Jace's life comes to an end
if this episode didn't make you cry you
might be a demon seriously this was one
tearjerker in the season two finale
Clary and Jace go to Lake Lynn to stop
Valentine a lot happens before they get
there but as soon as they get there
they're taken by surprise Valentine
shows up right behind them and stabs
Jace in the heart cue the flurry song
and the tears
first Alec feels that Jace is losing his
life through his parabatai bond then
see all the bonding moments between alak
and Jays and then they cut back to Clary
who's holding Jace and telling him to
save his strength one single solitary
tear rolls down from his eye and he
tells Clary he loves her before he stops
breathing and then all of the Clay's
loving hearts exploded all over their
TVs and that song by flurry just added
volumes to the heartbreak of Jace
slipping away
thank goodness Clary was able to command
the angel to bring Jace back then they
make out until Alec is he and Magnus
arrive at least they brought the vibe up
by going to a party to celebrate the end
of Valentine whew that was a super heavy
scene Jocelyn's untimely demise
all the true fans who are familiar with
the book series know that the
showrunners for Shadowhunters deviated a
bit from the books with this major plot
twist they said they knew that Clary
needed to go on a hero's journey so they
ended Jocelyn's life to give Clary a
great amount of adversity to overcome
they spoke with the author of the books
Cassandra Clare and got her permission
to make this major change she agreed
100% that it would make Clarisse journey
more profound many people were shocked
by this unfortunate turn of events
especially since Clary and Jocelyn had
just reconnected the funeral scene was
one of the most heartbreaking moments in
the show when Clary and Jace were
standing next to Jocelyn and they were
saying the names of the deceased Clary
choked on her words when she tried to
say her mother's name then she blurted
out mom and sobbed into Jace's chest
Jace had to say Jocelyn's name for Clary
and during that episode the stock price
for tissues skyrocketed fans were crying
their eyes out a bunch of fans posted
about their heartbreak on the show's
official YouTube channel it basically
looked like a sea of crying emojis when
Jace dropped Clary off a building in the
season 3 a finale
Lillis manipulation and torture campaign
on Jace was in full effect she was
punishing him for Jonathan's departure
from this earth so Jonathan started
visiting Jace in his dreams where he
slays Clary or convinces Jace to do the
deed himself Jace was pretty sure that
Lilith's owl was Jonathan's because of
the nightmare
but he was wrong Jayce was actually the
owl perhaps the worst part of that
discovery was when Jayce went to the
roof to escape Clary wasn't about to let
him get away
so she went after him what happened next
was the most brutal Shadowhunters battle
the fans have ever seen so many fans
have wanted Clary and Jace to end up
together but instead he tries to end her
life on a rooftop but maybe the most
gut-wrenching part of that whole battle
was the moment before he threw her off
the building he told her he didn't love
her not anymore he said of course lilith
erased his love for Clary but it was
still brutal for fans to watch all fans
want is to see those two together
instead they're doing battle on the
rooftop and one of them ends up
plummeting onto a parked car storeys
below ouch when Jace stabs Alec okay a
lot happened during season three's
midseason finale Jace was still Lilith's
owl and he was not being the best buddy
to the rest of the crew but there was a
particularly heartbreaking scene in the
episode that had us clinging to the
tissue box it was the scene where Jason
Alec were engaged in that huge battle
and Jace was being all Owly and taunting
Alec as he tried to stab him in the
chest he finally overpowered Alec and
the arrow pierced him but what had our
eyes filled with big ol alligator tears
was the way Alec forgave him and showed
such sincere compassion not only did
Alex say that he forgave him he said he
was sorry they couldn't save him
right as the arrow was piercing his
heart thank goodness Magnus showed up
when he did he used all of his magic to
free Jace from Lilith's control when
Jace all we had done Alec the regret on
his face was seriously heart crushing he
begged Magnus to save Alec Alec was
struggling to breathe but he managed to
say to Jace that he knew it wasn't him
and then Jace cried and then we all
cried Simon's family reunion in season 3
Heidi tries to convince Simon's mother
and sister that he's a vampire they
don't believe her so she plays a very
nasty trick to get her way she knows he
hasn't fed in a while she also knows
that his van
our instincts will take over at the
sight of blood even if it's from his
sister's neck when Heidi cuts Becky skin
Simon has overcome by his vampire hunger
he grabs his sister and feeds on her
while his mother watches
he nearly sucks the life out of her but
is he in Jordan burst in just in time
the real heartbreaking moment in this
scene comes when Simon stops and
realizes what he had just done then his
mother comes at him with a knife yelling
for him to stay away from the family and
that if he ever touches Becky again it
will be the last thing he ever does then
she says he's not her son she says that
he's a monster the look of pain and
Simon and his mother's eyes is
devastating but even more devastating
was when Simon compels his mother to
believe he's no longer alive and then
kisses her goodbye forever
seriously buckets of Tears over here
what happened to Clary the season 3 a
finale of Shadowhunters was packed full
of incredible moments now if you haven't
watched the mid-season finale yet this
is a major spoiler don't say we didn't
warn you so Lilith gets chase to capture
Clary and bring her back to Lilith then
she puts a rune on Clary that binds her
to Johnathan so as long as her heart
beats his will - then Simon tries to
bust open Jonathan's tomb then Lilith
goes after Simon but since Simon has the
Mark of Cain the attack backfires on
Lilith and blasts her back then
Jonathan's gross decayed arm grabs Clary
you simons mark makes Lilith start to
burn up she's getting sent back to Edom
which generates a huge explosion
consuming Lilith Clary and Jonathan
normal Jace comes back just in time to
find Simon who tells him he is
responsible for Clary's demise
so is she gone the executive producers
are warning fans to get ready for some
sadness when the first episode back airs
executive producer Todd Slavkin said
that Clary's friends reactions to the
loss of their friend was done in a
really kind of beautiful poetic way he
said they tried not to be too maudlin
but it's pretty emotional this show is
being cancelled after only three seasons
this might be the most heartbreaking
moment in the history of the whole show
grab your tissues are you ready all
right they just announced that
Shadowhunters is going to be cancelled
in the spring after only three seasons
fans are totally crushed apparently
there was some issue with Constantine
film the company that produces the show
all we know is that the show will wrap
after the second half of season three
and we'll end with an additional two our
season finale we've still got time to
hydrate and stock up on buckets to catch
all the tears right good Katherine
McNamara who plays Clary on the show
tweeted on June 5th that she just found
out about the cancellation she said she
and her cast mates are just as shocked
as the rest of the fans are she ended
with a hail and farewell my angels fans
are not taking this news lightly they
started the hashtag save Shadowhunters a
fan who goes by miss Alexis Chris
tweeted that the show is a safe haven an
escape and the reason so many have
learned to embrace who they really are
oh no here come the tears again so how
are you coping with the news did we miss
any heartbreaking moments from the show
if so tell us in the comments and thanks
for watching our 10 most heartbreaking
moments from Shadowhunters on the things
see you next time
[Music]
you